bon je crois que tout est en ordre
d'ailleurs
julie que plus tard un oui je vais voir
mon ami honnête mais c'est aussi mon ami
j'aurais dit dieu notre ami la lettre
oui oui on attend attend plus de minutes
oui j'ai une question à te poser pour
laquelle assieds toi et écoute musicale
[Musique]
noël je voudrais bien savoir comment il
faut faire pour devenir sage être
toujours au bénissant comme les enfants
sur les images
surtout quand on est comme moi avec des
rêves plein la tête
on a des gestes maladroits s'il te plaît
dit moi l'art sert
en vérité les plaisirs
et c'est gagné tu peux bien sage sans
savoir
tu es au taureau les gens autour de toi
c'est mario
[Musique]
thibault
arrive de temps en temps de partir en
claquant la porte ce n'est pas que je
sois méchant c'est la colère qui
m'emporte
c6 r
il arrive que jamais hagard avec les
meilleurs de mes copains et impôts sans
crier gare
en
vérité fait plaisir
ces camions tu peux bien ça sa voix
[Musique]
je veux bien essayer
pour diminuer mes bêtises de faire
plaisir au monde entier ce sera dur fois
que tu dis
son format est un secret monsieur du
snop et le acteurs julie mademoiselle
futaie compte aussi parfois des erreurs
j'aimerais bien savoir comment il faut
faire pour devenir sage d'être toujours
obéissant comme les enfants sur les
images
agen surtout quand on est aux mains avec
des rails
la tête on a des gestes mal à mais j'ai
bien au final
je vais vous lire un poème de cécile
perrin qui s'appelle danse 1 écoutez
bien
qu'ils dansent parmi le teint est ce
rayon un lutin peut-être un petit lapin
est ce une abeille en maraude une
couleuvre qui rôde un lézard couleurs
d'émeraude je ne sais mais je sais bien
que tout dans ce matin parmi les touffes
de teint que l'esprit est une abeille la
subtile les harkis veille un lutin qui
s'émerveillent ou bien ce petit lapin
qui jouent et brody soudain
toof d'être c'est joli tetra je vais
vous allez jouer maintenant c'est moi
qui mets tout seul françois excuse moi
de te déranger encore une fois mais
julie n'est toujours pas revenue mais
non mon dieu elle est partie à l'autre
bout de l'île chez son ami le legs temps
c'est bien je pense qu'il ne va plus
tarder maintenant tu n'as qu'à
l'attendre ici en non non non non ça ne
fait rien on je reviendrai un peu plus
tard je vais faire quelques pas comme tu
voudras mentir
pas tout à fait julie l'oled va bien oui
très bien tu sais qu'elle est en train
d'arracher sa maison ça va être très
joli
10 mois il s'est rien passé en mon
absence à j-6 monsieur du ce noble
facteurs et casimir ont tous demandé de
parler qu'est-ce qui me voulaient bien
casimir voulait casimir voulais te
demander des anchois pour mettre dans
une glace le facteur voulais te remettre
un mandat un mandat shaq à la et
monsieur 19 alors là monsieur des snobs
il n'a rien voulu dire mystère nathan
épisode
travail je retourne à mon coeur entendu
mon plus beau au calme françois tient le
plus beau bocal a été percé plus tu es
sûr qu'il n'était pas déjà cassé quand
il est parti mais certaines tu n'as rien
entendu non j'ai rien entendu du tout
non pourtant à ce discours c'est curieux
non mais je suis sorti deux ou trois
fois du jardin moi je voudrais bien
élucider ce mystère quand même mais moi
aussi mais je joue à pas la solution et
est même monsieur vers le col mais ce ne
serait pas capable de te donner à temps
je sais qu'il va midi à trouver le
coupable j'ai oublié de fermer mon cas
c'est au fon il est resté sur
enregistrement pendant mon absence vos
branches de vite pour l'écouter
[Musique]
mais j'ai choisi d'être pacte
mademoiselle julie est cool en
chirurgie n'est pas la bonne il non
monsieur muscle je reviendrai à bientôt
salut factor bonjour casimir ah [ __ ]
[Musique]
ça lui quasiment à sec ce soir
je suis toujours là
ça n'est pas comme avec tout ça non non
j'ai j'ai pas très bien compris on va
recommencer oui tu as raison prêt nous
allons faire très attention au bruit des
pas qui s'approche et qui s'éloigne
c'est ce qu'on va faire on va aller avec
les enfants voir ça au tableau noir -
faire un croquis ça va être plus facile
les enfants venaient tous asseyez vous
sur le bord
via avec l'enregistrement gelé alors
vous avez compris des sortants ce qui se
passe quelqu'un pour l'absence de julie
a cassé son plus beau bocal et nous
allons aussi grâce à un enregistrement
de deviner quel est le coupable or à
bien faire attention au bruit des pas
des personnes qui arrivent et qui
repartent cherchez bien celle là est
signé le fiasco de julie julie envoie
l'enregistrement s'il te plaît
[Applaudissements]
qu est ce que
l on a toujours le secteur
reviendra bientôt il repart
pourtant fait c'est pas
les acteurs sont venues des capitales
c'est françois c'est moi
que je suis reparti hélas ce bruit
c'est ça
je suis du snob est revenu
et il repart
donc les enfants vous avez entendu le
bruit cassé et qui était présent
c'est casimir donc seul casimir étaient
présents à ce moment là ouais il faut
nous rendre à l'évidence et oui
malheureusement
bien maintenant nous n'avons plus qu'à
l'attendre
dont le
à julie tu es là je voudrais des anchois
jade aucun pussy casimir n'aurais tu pas
par hasard casser vos plus jolie bocal
de bonbons ouais à nous dans la vie tout
est bien que je vais être obligé de
traiter de menteur parce que nous savons
fort bien que tu étais le seul près du
kiosque quand ce bocal a été cassé
oui en effet j'ai j'étais là à mais j'ai
tout vu mais ce n'est pas moi et je ne
peux rien dire vous voyez on ne ment pas
nous avons la preuve que tu étais là bon
on va croyez ce que vous voulez mais ce
n'est pas moi
leona
junique justement je suis désolé j'ai
complètement oublié la trappe de mon
tunnel et j'ai cassé tombons cas alors
c'est pour ça j'ai apporté de la colle
pour que tu puisses le réparer j'avais
complètement oublié ce tunnel
et dire que nous accusions casimir
il ne faut jamais juger trop vite